my
first memory of
being at whatcom is going in through the
main front doors and
seeing this beautiful beautiful house
like gorgeous building um and thinking
that it might be okay that it might be
safe here and it
might get better here was within the
first few days of me being at whatcom
that i met the abuser
nima's mental health problems began when
she was barely a teenager
she was referred to cams that's the
nhs's mental health service for children
i moved house when i was 14 and
that was when my mental health started
deteriorating so i went from
being sort of quite anxious and
self-harming and having low self-esteem
to um feeling quite suicidal
her treatment eventually led to whatcom
hall
a privately run residential psychiatric
unit
paid for and commissioned by the nhs
but instead of being protected and
helped
nima was exposed to a serial sex
offender
i remember that he used to give me
lots of sort of special treatment so
he'd spend more of his time with me
than with other patients there when he
was on shift and
if i was on one-to-one support so i
needed somebody
with me all the time then he would often
be my one-to-one
so he would find a way to uh
to change or adapt the the shift
and the staff that were on shift so that
he could spend more time
with me did you think anything unnatural
was happening then
not at all not at all i had no idea
that what was happening was grooming
absolutely no idea
right from the beginning with with
marcus i
i felt that i loved him i felt that i
was in love with him in
in the kind of relationship you'd have
between a girlfriend and a boyfriend
not for any minute did i either
think or worry or feel that he was doing
something wrong
nemo was just 16 still a highly
vulnerable
child but despite this her abuser began
to escalate their relationship
the longer i was there and the more
leave that
i was taking with him the more that we
were going on these escorted walks that
the further it progressed and
so it moved on to he
he was kissing me he he kissed me and
and
initially that was sort of like he
kissed me on the cheek and then it
moved to the lips and then it moved
to him touching different parts of my
body nema did not know that the alarm
had been raised about her abuser before
she eventually told a member of staff
what was happening
initially she seemed surprised
but she didn't say that it was
wrong or that it was bad or that it
wasn't
right she seemed surprised how did you
feel after you told her this
i
it's really hard to say exactly
how telling her
made me feel because i'd at the time i
couldn't really recognize
that actually i was telling her because
i needed her help
nemo was discharged in june 2017.
but the most serious assault took place
the day
after she left whatcom hall and arranged
to meet her abuser
in his hometown sheldon it was meant to
be like a
birthday treat for me so he bought me a
necklace
with a little pendant on it and
um he'd brought a little picnic
so we were sat in a woods
near his home and in quite a secluded
area
and we we put this picnic blanket out
and and
we we were citing and chatting and
laughing
and um and then
i took off my top
i just remember feeling sick just
feeling really really sick and having
this
horrible gut feeling that something was
wrong
marcus daniel pleaded guilty to 21
offenses
he was sentenced to 11 years in prison
for sexually abusing
three teenage girls in his care
nema's ordeal did not end after she
raised the alarm about
danielle's abuse her mental health
deteriorated
and she was told to return for treatment
back
to whatcom hall i don't know how
anybody would would have thought that
after
experiencing something so traumatic
that the correct response the right
response the response that would have
been best for me and my mental health
was
to put me back into the environment that
had been so traumatic
but back into the environment where i've
been abused
i was my family where we all just we
felt so
voiceless and confused and hurt and
betrayed
that that there was there felt like no
point in raising objections
it was like the damage had been done
danielle
is responsible for abusing nemo but
she also blames her care provider
the hunter they absolutely failed
in their duty of care that there were so
many
obvious signs and signals and red flags
the entire time that i was
there as a patient at wacom hall there
there were so
many signs that that suggested that that
what was happening between me and marcus
was
was wrong was was horribly wrong
nima is suing the hunticum group at the
time it was owned by four seasons
healthcare group
but isn't anymore in response to nema's
story they told sky news
we deeply regret the harm that miss hunt
experienced
while in the care of whatcom hall which
at the time was owned
and independently managed by the
hunticum group
whatcom hall failed to meet the expected
standards
and was subsequently closed in 2017.
we are unable to comment further on this
specific case
until any legal action has concluded
since the closure of whatcom hall two
other units
run by the huntington group have also
been closed following concerns around
the care provided
another unit was placed into special
measures
at the start of this year the current
owner of the hunticum group has told us
improvements have been made since that
inspection
nema blames an inadequate children's
mental health system
for exposing her to a sexual predator
free to abuse
vulnerable children i don't think i
would have ever needed to go
into psychiatric hospital if
there had been appropriate cam support
in place seeing somebody
once every two weeks was not enough for
me at that time i was really poorly and
i needed help
and i needed somebody to really
be invested in my care nima's case
raises more
serious questions about the care we
provide to our most
vulnerable nema has shown a spotlight
on some profound inadequacies in the the
mental health provision that we give to
children and young people we raised
nima's case
with former health secretary jeremy hunt
he's the chair of the health select
committee
who is holding an inquiry into
children's mental health
clearly there are individuals who did
the most
abhorrent things you have to take full
responsibility under the law
for their care but the system uh
needs improving that is ultimately the
responsibility of the secretary of state
not just matt hancock now but me when i
was secretary of state
and i do believe that huge effort is
being made
to improve the care that people like
nema receive
but sometimes the progress feels
painfully slow
and that is because fundamentally what
we need is a big
expansion of our capacity to deliver
mental health
at all levels nhs england responded to
neima's case by saying
measures are in place so that patients
receive high quality
safe care from the organization's
commission to provide
care and contracts are regularly
monitored
to ensure this happens the nhs
has significantly increased mental
health support for people
in the community an additional 975
million pounds every year will be
invested
in community care by 2023
2024 nima entered into the system as a
vulnerable 13 year old
needing help with her mental health
she's now 20.
i have a diagnosis now of complex
post-traumatic
stress disorder and as a result of of
what i lived through
at whatcom hall of the abuse i endured
there
i still self-harm
the severity of my self-harm has has
really changed since
i've been at whatcom and
i struggle more than i ever have now
with
with my body in its physical form
and the idea of having a woman's body
feels really uh
almost sickening to me because of
because of what marcus did
because of what he made me believe about
myself